like i i like i didn't understand how
something could become like a choking
hazard like how food could become a
proper choking hazard until lego huh oh
yeah no no no no no like like
like as an adult i'm talking like
like i understand as a child that a lot
of things can become joking houses but i
didn't understand it until i went to
america for the first time and had like
my first american steak where they it's
it's like oh i know what you mean and
where they just like it's it's not a
steak it's just a slab of meat at that
point man they just they like plop it on
and you just like wow i kind of feel
like hannibal lecter right now man like
jesus christ and then you start chewing
into this thing and then you're like and
you start chewing it and it's like it's
just a lot of meat yeah i've never
this can be taken out of context i've
never had that much meat in my mouth at
once like just just in general right and
uh was it too much meat in your mouth
yeah it was a bit too much me in my
mouth
it was very hard to swallow and i'm just
like jesus okay i can understand how
people can choke on steaks now like but
also if they use like a really cheap cut
of meat yeah holy [ __ ] it's like chewing
on leather it's like a dog toy sometimes
it's good though it's like it's like
beef flavored gum no what the [ __ ] that
is the worst take i've ever heard
what the [ __ ] no when it's chewy what
did you just say
meat flavored gum this is just chewing
and the more you chew but no more flavor
will not break down yeah no matter how
much you chew you cannot get it to
separate beef flavored gum holy [ __ ]
what this is like that scene in the 40
year old virgin where like they're
describing the feel of like breasts yeah
just like yeah it's like a bag of sand
bag of sand
another one is too chewy that i
[Music]
in japan and it's like a chain called uh
what is it like inari steaks
yeah
it's [ __ ] abhorrent steak well so i
went there and uh yeah i went with a
friend and we're both ordering and i was
you know stake in japan is quite
expensive to get a good steak yeah and
they bought the cheapest steak but which
also had the option to have the biggest
size out of any of the steak so none of
the other steaks went over like 300
grams right yeah
for some reason this one state that was
super cheap or something it was like it
was some like it was called like but it
was named something like man meat or
something it was like
it was like something supposed to be
manly it wasn't it wasn't labeled
it wasn't no it's called monster meat or
something that doesn't even work
it was called like monster cut meat and
now i was like what the [ __ ] is that so
i was like you know what the sirloin you
get about half the meat it's about
double the price i'm sticking with the
sirloin yeah because yeah you want to
enjoy my meal yeah so so we're eating
and they're like the first piece they're
like [ __ ] this is
quite tough i'm hearing them chewing
chewing chewing chewing and i'm like are
you good and they're like
it's really hearty yeah they managed to
eat one buyer and then i felt bad so i
was like yeah do you want to have like
we'll trade pieces like yeah so i gave
them two pieces of mine and i took two
pieces of theirs because i felt bad
because it was terrible yeah i nearly
[ __ ] choked on how bad this steak was
because it you literally couldn't break
it apart yeah you literally come on and
and you like [ __ ]
and like it takes so much effort that
you have to start breathing through your
mouth
in order to like get the air and talk
you know when you get to that point
where you're chewing me so much you're
like have i gotten this meat glob into a
size that i think is okay to swallow
yeah because i don't think i can break
it down yeah yeah
yeah
that i won't show you and it's and it's
just like one is it soft enough that you
don't choke into sometimes you just cut
off like a bit too big of a piece it
doesn't break down enough and you just
have to like pray to god that your
esophagus can just like squeeze this
[ __ ] meat down
an absolute rookie era we took our take
out and we had plastic forks oh
there was absolutely no chance that
because they'd already pre-cut it into
like pieces like this yeah which is like
too too much yeah these these pieces of
meat from this this cow that i assume
was just benching all the other cows i
don't know what the [ __ ] was going on
with this cow to have meat that was
ripped that man i thought the fda was
probably testing all the [ __ ] drugs
so he's doing some roids or something it
was insane how muscular this cow was
like good cuts there though
they did but
this
sirloin steak that was like this big was
like thirty dollars yeah yeah it was
terrible in which case you're better off
going to like a higher end statement
yeah yeah and the only reason i went
that's because everything else was
closed it was the only place yeah
they're open pretty late i mean what did
you expect from a place that's literally
called suddenly steak yeah that at least
it's cool
and then suddenly
it's kind of like japanese food in the
uk it's like
i'm not expecting much yeah and i didn't
go in there expecting a good steak it's
like the same i didn't expect good steak
to be in japan because japan doesn't
really have japan imports most of their
normal stuff yeah in terms of like steak
steak like japan steak isn't great you
know they import nearly all of their
steak that isn't like the kobe yeah like
australia yeah australia in america
uh yeah so
generally beefier is quite bad unless
it's like kobe beef but i get sick of
kobe beef i mean we've talked about this
previously do you know do you know what
i miss
that i i found is like apparently only
in europe peppercorn sauce yes like
it's
amazing steak sauce yeah it's like the
best steak sauce i've ever had i mean i
know peppercorns and you only get it
it's like it's like it's like a creamy
literal peppercorn sauce
i've i thought it was like a universal
thing because in england you have steak
you have a wood peppercorn sauce
and it's just it tastes so [ __ ] good
and then i only realized moving out of
england even though other places in the
world have like better quality meats
like japan or america they have like
better quality meats than a lot of the
steaks you can find in the uk but it's
just where the [ __ ] are you going huh
where are you going i mean i'm in
brighton there's not there's not a great
steak in brighton honestly really good
stuff you're missing out god maybe maybe
but like the peppercorn sauce would
always save that steak for me because
like the the two of them just tasted so
good together and like it's it's
something you just don't find elsewhere
in the world apart from in europe
apparently that's the only place i've
found i swear i've seen it in some
restaurants in america i don't know
though maybe i have
like your steak is mid comment i didn't
properly get until i realized that every
steak here is with salt and pepper and
i'm just like okay now wasabi which i
just don't think is good on stage
it depends it depends on
in every steak here every steak i've had
in japan and most of the places i've had
i've been in america as well you have
the
you have the option of salt and pepper
or in america you have aju uh which is i
think it's just
this liquid that comes out of the meat
yeah the meat
it's just the meat juice
it's literally the meat juices they pour
it back on yeah yeah yeah yeah
like my dad used to do that
go to lorries here they have a lorries
yeah okay and i'm just like there's so
many different steak sources out there
like peppercorn and red wine sauce as
well which goes [ __ ] amazing with
steaks and no no nobody does it and i'm
just like why why like i get steak
tastes good but there's only so many
times i can have salt and pepper and
steak
uk steak with ketchup
yeah that's weird do they yeah i don't
know a1 i could understand it's kind of
ketchup e i like a1 we don't we didn't
have anyone in australia
what's wrong with you guys
why why'd you do that this this is why
everyone comes in everyone's like
everyone mocks me you know and british
people for growing up with this we don't
understand we're truly overpowered we
have literally no benchmark for food it
is so [ __ ] that when i go it's the wild
west
i literally go anywhere and i'm like
[ __ ] this shit's busting and it's got
like cockroaches in it and i'm like damn
this shit's so good
i i appreciate the boston i i i can i
think i can do you one worse because i
think uh
in thailand they eat
pizza with ketchup
what kind are you okay with that it's
tomato tomato puree tomato ketchup
it's just just a normal pizza like a
cheese pizza yeah what what other kind
of pizza is what i don't know i like
pepperoni or [ __ ] i'm gonna be dying
i'm gonna be honest if i'm at my house
i put tomato ketchup on the side and i
dunk the crusts in it yeah i do that
that makes sense that's good
i do the mayonnaise and ketchup
combination i don't need to do that yeah
i don't